[Musique]
Hélène buzetti allait castongue bonsoir
bonsoir alors le spectacle de la Fête
nationale à Québec c'est le 23 juin donc
retour de grands spectacles et là vous
avez vu mesdames et messieurs peut-être
sur Twitter ou ailleurs ça roule depuis
un certain temps c'est pire que jamais
et aimait le Bilodeau le Parti québécois
qui n'ira pas au spectacle parce que
traditionnellement les gens des partis
les parties Québécois étaient invités à
aller prendre la parole à ce spectacle
n'ira pas parce que Émile Bilodeau
est présent ils estiment qu'il a été
trop dur avec le PQ je vous fais je vous
fais lire deux trois tweets pour vous
mettre dans le contexte alors d'abord
Mégane Perry Melançon qui n'ira pas et
dire la question ici c'est pourquoi le
mouvement national du Québécois le
désigné comme porte-parole l'événement
alors qu'il a non seulement dénigré mon
chef mais souhaiter la mort du Parti
québécois tenu des propos sur la laïcité
qui ne sont pas tous rassant tout
rassembleurs donc elle a ni repas elle
non merci Réponse des mails bilodeaux on
va vous faire un
esti de bons choses si vous voulez me
canceler je vous propose d'aller voir ce
que font les républicains aux États-Unis
de l'expérience dans le domaine alors à
vous la parole est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une
tempête dans un verre d'eau et mets le
Bilodeau depuis la dernière campagne et
même avant et contre la loi sur la
laïcité et pas d'accord avec le PQ sur
autre chose mais là on parle d'une fête
nationale quel est le problème alors
Alec
est-ce que c'est une tempête dans un
verre d'eau peut-être que concernant la
fête nationale elle-même oui dans la
mesure où est-ce que le mouvement
national des Québécois qui organise la
Fête nationale aurait pu être choisir un
animateur un peu moins associé à un
parti politique ça certainement c'est
vrai que le dos depuis longtemps et près
de Québec solidaire mais fait campagne
avec Gabriel ado Dubois lors des
dernières élections on n'aime pas le PQ
sans cache pas alors c'est vrai que si
on veut être rassembleur mettons que
c'est sûr que c'est peut-être pas la
bonne personne à inviter ceci dit le
droit à ses opinions il y a le droit
d'aimer un autre parti souverainiste que
le Parti québécois il a le droit d'être
en désaccord avec la loi 21 ce n'est pas
être anti souverainiste ou
anti-nationaliste de ne pas aimer la loi
21 mais c'est sûr que de l'inviter à
aller créer des remous et la partie
québécois a décidé de jouer dans ce film
là et de d'embrasser la controverse pour
dire ben nous on y va pas donc est-ce
que ça c'est vraiment une tempête dans
un verre d'eau peut-être l'eau c'est
moins de temps dans un verre d'eau je
trouve c'est que c'est assez
représentatif
de l'animosité qui règne entre certains
militants de Québec solidaire certaines
têtes d'affiches de Québec solidaire et
le Parti québécois et puis la tentative
de fusion manquée là à l'époque de
Jean-François Alizée on a ménage pas nos
coups de part et d'autre pour saillir
souvent en privé de temps en temps en
public comme on le voit là mais il y a
une divergence profonde d'opinions sur
la manière dont on devrait traiter les
questions d'identité d'identité
nationale par rapport à la laïcité par
exemple par rapport à l'immigration
entre autres par rapport à certains
dossiers où on a des deux côtés là des
vues irré-conciliables et ça part un peu
de là parce que la chicane avec Emile
Bilodeau parle de là à la base et là on
assiste à sur une grande scène à une
chicane qui couvre depuis maintenant
plusieurs années entre les partisans des
deux partis politiques puis on a même
démonstration donc ça c'est pas une
tempête dans un verre d'eau ça c'est
vraiment là ça résiste fondamentale
entre les deux parties il y a des gens
qui se détestent là
en fait intéressant j’écoutais ce
qu'elle disait puis en fait c'est
seulement une nouvelle version de de
cette bataille sur ce qu'est être
québécois alors aujourd'hui c'est sur
cette dichotomie peut-être qu'il existe
comme comme avec Guinée de l'expliquer
leur QS et le Parti québécois mais je
suis retourné un peu en arrière parce
que je me disais voyons est-ce que c'est
vrai que c'est fight long toujours été
non partisanes parce que je dois dire
d'emblée j'ai pas de d'opinion très
arrêté sur ce sujet est-ce que c'est un
bon choix un mauvais choix j'étais pas
certaine mais je disais est-ce que c'est
vrai que c'est ça doit être mon
partenaire donc je suis retourné dans
quelques années charnière je pensais aux
années à l'année 90 par exemple cette
année où la veille la Saint-Jean il y
avait eu l'échec de l'accord du lacmitch
et l'élection de gens chrétiens comme
chef du Parti libéral du Québec du
Canada ou alors 94 juste après
l'élection du Bloc québécois comme
opposition officielle à Ottawa et juste
avant la fameuse élection plutôt
référendaire là où qui a porté le PQ au
pouvoir et dans les deux cas la
Saint-Jean avait été extrêmement
politique on parlait de ces questions là
évidemment tout revenait à ce qu'on est
souverainiste ou fédéraliste alors la
question à l'époque c'était être
québécois à être fier québécois est-ce
que c'est être nécessairement pro pour
la souveraineté ou est-ce qu'on peut
être aussi pro-québec fier d'être
Québécois mais vouloir rester dans le
Canada donc à être fédéraliste alors
dans le fond c'est une nouvelle
itération de cette même querelle mais
qui s'articule peut-être autour de Dax
un peu différent mais finalement cette
fête qui se veut rassembleuse semble
être très bonne à créer plus elle
cristallise parfois les divisions dans
le et là on le voit que entre QS et le
PQ bon elle n'ira pas aux dernières
nouvelles à voir par ailleurs parlons-en
de QS de Québec solidaire il y a cette
course pour la cour porte-parole je vais
vous faire entendre les trois candidates
de cette course qui se sont exprimées en
fin de semaine
j'ai fait la démonstration en 2018 puis
en 2022 que je suis capable de non
seulement faire percer Québec solidaire
dans une région où il y avait pas déjà
d'appui solide et également de conserver
ses appuis là moi je le sens beaucoup
dans la région de l'esprit qui est
l'endroit où j'ai le plus de tribunes
actuellement que je suis capable de
rejoindre les gens qui s'intéressaient
pas à Québec solidaire auparavant ou
s'intéressait pas à la politique du tout
cette démonstration là elle est
clairement faite dans ma région je pense
en tant qu'auporterole de Québec
solidaire ça me permettrait de le faire
à l'échelle du Québec
l'idée c'est pas de mettre en opposition
les villes avec les régions c'est je
dirais la moitié de la population habite
dans la ruralité du Québec il y a des
sensibilités qui sont des différentes il
y a des réalités qui sont différentes
d'être capable d'avoir quelqu'un qui
peut en parler qui peut incarner aussi
ces enjeux là c'est réalité je pense que
ça va permettre que des gens qui se
reconnaissent davantage dans notre
discours
ce n'est pas une course qui est plus
indépendante c'est plus que l'autre ou
de dire à des gens à vous tu l'es pas
assez tué il y a des gens qui font qui
moi je fais pas ça moi je veux
rassembler puis à Québec solidaire la
question de l'indépendance elle est dans
notre ADN la fierté le nationalisme
c'est pas une marque protégée par la
kakoudou ou le Parti québécois Québec
solidaire remporte ce projet-là et ils
m'ont suis fière de juste que les
Québécois l'entendent encore plus
madame Gazal qui veut remettre justement
en parler de souveraineté il y a une
seconde la souveraineté au centre en
fait davantage au centre Christine
l'abri d'y écouter les régions simples
et d'ailleurs le coup chef le dit en fin
de semaine si dépasse pas un espèce de
plafond de verre il y arriveront pas
alors que penser de cette course
qu'est-ce que ça incarne justement
Hélène mais justement moi je pense que
le grand enjeu ils l'ont mis le doigt
dessus c'est l'importance d'élargir les
horizons de ce parti c'est intéressant
ce que Gabriel Nadaud Dubois disait
comme on peut compter il y en a un bon
côté des choses c'est qu'on peut compter
sur des Assises des bases solides on
notre 16 17% d'appui il ne fléchit pas
il est solide comme le rock c'est vrai
que c'est très positif mais le côté
négatif de ça c'est qu'on a de la
difficulté à croître au-delà de ce 17 %
et je pense que c'est propre de
n'importe quelle partie politique qui
est très idéologique je dirais même
dogmatique ce sont des partis qui
réussissent à galvaniser
leur convaincus sont très convaincus
mais ceci dit ça nuit beaucoup à leur
potentiel de croissance et je trouve que
à Ottawa par exemple il y a un parti qui
est un peu dans une situation similaire
c'est celui du Parti conservateur 2.0 là
le parti fusionné depuis 2003 qui est un
parti qui a une base militante très très
motivée mais qui est
attaché à des idées très très fixes qui
ne veut pas en démorder ce faisant au de
la difficulté à croître et de
difficultés à aller chercher le pouvoir
même lorsque il fait face à un parti un
gouvernement fatigué et donc c'est un
peu seul des filles de Québec solidaire
c'est que de réussir à garder cette base
mais à faire des compromis à élargir les
horizons pour plaire à un plus grand
nombre de personnes sortir des villes
mais donc élargir point Alex
je vais répéter ce que j'ai répété
souvent là quand on parle d'un Québec
solidaire et des régions oui ça reste
difficile oui c'est un parti qui est
urbain mais aux dernières élections mise
à part deux députés il y a aucun député
d'aucun parti politique en région sauf
sur la coalition à venir Québec il y a
Joël Arsenault Pascal Bérubé qui sont là
grâce à leur nom alors notoriété tout le
reste sont des députés de Québec
solidaire alors il y a beaucoup de
parties qui pourraient se dire on a des
difficultés en région pas seulement qui
se dit mais partout
c'est quand même ça que ça a donné mais
oui c'est vrai que du travail à faire
chez Québec solidaire pour être plus
pragmatique il y a aussi cette étiquette
qui leur colle à la peau d'être trop à
gauche d'être pelleté un peu de nuage de
pas s'intéresser à ce que les gens hors
des grands centres pensent il y a
certaines politiques dans leur
proposition qui ont rappelé ça lors des
dernières élections le bonus malus pour
les véhicules énergivores c'est une
bonne idée en théorie mais quand on vit
en région puis qu'on est avec un gros
cas de par 4 parce qu'on a besoin de ça
pour travailler dans les forêts en
agriculture ça a moins bien passé on
avait ce qu'on avait bien calculé ça
bref il y a certainement un examen ils
ont réflexion
malgré oui dossiers de Rouen ils ont
quand même perdu l'habitude et ça fait
mal et je pense qu'ils auraient mis le
garder parce que mélise laissa-terrier
ont été très habile très bonne dans le
dossier de Rouen de Random une grande
partie de du fait que c'est devenu un
grand sujet national lui revient les
électeurs visiblement droit de Randa on
préférait récompenser la CAQ pour les
quatre années au pouvoir mais oui il y a
du travail à faire il y a beaucoup de
travail à faire parce que le danger
c'est qu'on étiquette à un moment donné
que c'est le gars comme étant seulement
un parti urbain il ne souhaite pas ça
alors il y a une réflexion à faire mais
ce qui est intéressant dans les extraits
que vous avez choisi aussi et vous
recherchez cette mérite la palme pour ça
ça aide ça encapsulait parfaitement le
début de course de ces trois
candidates-là c'est à dire au magasin
qui elle va parler beaucoup de
souveraineté des complexée était assez
coté pour cette raison là Christine
l'abri qui dit vous savez oui la
souveraineté comme un moyen comme un
autre pot par exemple diminuer la
pauvreté et lutter contre les
changements climatiques avoir une crise
du logement qui se résorbe et vous avez
une liste laissez un terrain qui dit
écoutez 50 % de la population du Québec
vit en région il faut penser à eux il
faut adapter notre discours évidemment
qu'il va y avoir des nuances dans la
position de chacun mais sur la course la
ligne de départ est intéressante les
militants vont avoir un véritable choix
entre trois femmes là par rapport à ce
qu'elles vont proposer comme orientation
pour la partie politique et donc même si
ça commence en nous on a une bonne idée
quand même des lignes de force et ça ça
va être intéressant à suivre alors
Camille vous avez reçu tu as reçu
l'étoile cette année vraiment Camille
pour les extraits que parce que du monde
derrière ça se fait pas tout seul ça
fait
oui Chantal nous a presque
fait trépigner jeudi en disant les
élections partielles
il y a plein de choses à surveiller ce
soir je vous montre la carte bon Notre
Dame de grâce-houissement au Québec
c'est rouge je pense avoir le récit
c'est intéressant de savoir c'est la
fille de Bob gaming ancienne président
du parti qui se présente partage let's
go je me rends je me rends donc au même
tourba c'est monsieur Bernier est-ce
qu'il va monter ou descendre les
conservateurs mais elle nous disait
Oxford
à surveiller parce que l'ancien
conservateur fait campagne pour les
libéraux et il y a aussi Winnipeg
s'entre-sud alors Hélène qu'est-ce que
vous surveillez ce soir oui évidemment
que ça serait très surprenant que la
composition de la chambre se trouve
métamorphosée à la suite de ces quatre
élections là il y a deux rouges deux
bleus ça devrait rester comme ça mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des des
lectures plus fines qu'on peut faire qui
peut être intéressantes même dans Notre
Dame de Grâce par exemple est-ce que
toute cette histoire de Monsieur Garnaud
par rapport aux langues officielles le
C13 il avait mené campagne là-dessus
finalement le gouvernement réussit à
mettre le couvercle sur cette
insatisfaction du western de Montréalais
les anglophones de Montréal
qu'arrive-t-il moi je trouve intéressant
quand même que le cochon du Parti vert
se présente dans cette circonscription
est-ce qu'il pourrait canaliser une
partie de de vote de mécontentement je
suis pas en train de prédire l'élection
département
mais ça pourrait être intéressant et
évidemment vous avez parlé de les yeux
de portage avec Maxime Bernier j'ai très
hâte de voir ce qui va arriver avec ce
côté-là c'était la circonscription en
2021 ou le parti de Maxime Bernier a
obtenu le plus haut score dans tout le
pays en presque 22% des votes est-ce
qu'il réussira à maintenir un tel score
on sait que monsieur Bernier leur a
vraiment campé extrêmement à droite dans
cette campagne sur la question des
avortement et les interdirait parce un
certain âge la personne étranges il y a
dit qui interdirait les toutes les
interventions médicales chez les
personnes de moins de 18 ans il y a même
dit que lui permettrait l'usage de la
force même l'étale pour protéger son
domicile lors d'une invasion par exemple
à fond il est allé très très à fond
j'aimerais voir qu'est-ce qui va arriver
avec ça très bien alors Alain qu'on
surveillera aussi
Axford le score des conservateurs s'ils
veulent prendre le pouvoir ilenait tout
à l'heure c'est intéressant il faut
élargir la barre il faut qu'il prenne
des compteurs un jour peut-être pas ce
soir mais il faut qu'il prenne un jour
ouais et d'un Winnipeg on s'attend pas
nécessairement ce que les conservateurs
gagnent parce que le fils de Jim car est
assez populaire les numéros devraient
garder cette circonscription là mais là
déjà appartenu au conservateur cette
circonscription à Winnipeg s'entre-sud
lors de la majorité conservatrice de
Steven Harper c'est le genre de
circonscription que les conservateurs
doivent gagner ils veulent devenir
majoritaire adieu dans la chambre des
commerces merci beaucoup à bientôt au
revoir au revoir